hey everyone uh we will just wait a few
more minutes for everyone to join in uh
feel free to say hello in the chat and
where are you from
have to get to know you my name is
philip i'm from germany
or australia 3am
early bird i would say
maybe they're a late person like me
okay i think we can start maybe a few
more people will join in um this won't
be an issue since we are starting a
short little introduction so welcome to
our first workshop of our hopefully long
workshop series about using hiking face
transformers with amazon sagemaker the
first workshop will be oriented about
training a hugging phase transformer
model on amazon sagemaker and directly
deploying it afterwards to sagemaker as
a search maker endpoint for
running some predictions
today i'm joining um myself is nate and
merve from our developer advocate team
and then mckee from aws he has a
solution startup solution ahi tech and
will you will tell you a bit more about
amazon sagemaker and what sagemaker is
um before we we we get um ready um here
are a few links for you to like reach
out to us so we have a new released um
discord channel where you can join
there's a new
channel
called sagemaker nlp
um where you can ask questions during
the workshop or like after workshop if
you're like running some of the examples
at home or at work
and then we have a forum where you can
also ask questions there's a dedicated
stagemaker channel and then you can find
everything we are going to show today on
github and um yeah these links will be
shared again in the chat so you can
access them
and then material stage is yours
okay hello everyone thank you for
joining i will share my screen and pass
through a couple of slides to present
the
adwords email vision
so the vision of aws is to make a
machine learning accessible for all the
customers if you are developer data
scientist or business user we should
have a solution to to achieve your goal
so we signed a strong partnership with
eugene face
today as you know again face is like the
most popular open source company
providing state-of-the-art nlp
technology and on the other end we have
a amazon sage maker that offer a high
performance resource to train and use
your nlp model
so the adobe sml stack is composed of
three layers so at the bottom one
you have the infrastructure layer where
we can provide you some gpu some
dedicated chip for the inference
but also some deep learning container
that includes tensorflow pytorch apache
and newly
ergin phase
on top of that you have a
you have the amazon sage maker we will
do a deep dive on that one that helps
data scientists to focus on the science
part and
let the heavy lifting of managing the
infant secure to adobes and on top of
that breaks you have the iml services
where it has a
really
service where you don't need to have any
knowledge in science but you can still
use it to power your website or
application
so uh introducing the new organ face
experience in stage maker so we have
created with again face what we call a
deep learning container a dlc
that will work both for training and
inference and for the two frameworks by
torch and tensorflow
again phase estimator is like directly
included in the sagemaker sdk that will
allow you to really uh easily length
your script
in a scalable way and also because
definitely
way
without worry about docker because you
just provide the script and we'll run it
for you
we have a comprehensive
gallery of example that you can read and
inspire you to create a
new application with again face and sage
maker
and at least
at the end we have the support so it's
maintained is supported by aws so if you
have already a subscription to the id
based support we can help you on that
one
so what are the benefits for using
eigenface and same maker first is like
cost effectiveness because we
we optimize search maker to scale for
the performance and the efficiencies at
the reduced cost and you can leverage or
spare capacity uh of instances that we
call the spot instance to go further and
reduce the cost for non-critical
workload
we are mlx ready so you have an
automated metadata persistence you can
search the search mechanize store you
you can log
your
the log will be included in cloudwatch
and you can monitor debug your profile
your model
and create experience
it's scalable so you can run a cluster
of gpu with
an efficient data parameter and model
parallel distribution
provided by sagemaker and the ability to
launch several jobs at the same time and
at aws security job zero so we raise the
bar above the security and you will you
we we provide a mechanism to fully
encrypt
your workload at rest and influences and
you can leverage the pc connectivity and
the fine-grained access where i am
so the benefit of the organ space dlc is
really a top quality is directly
supported by eugene face and aws is that
being tested and including the latest uh
ergin face and innovation
advanced innovation
it will remove the heavy lifting of
creating
an easier self manage you don't have to
provide docker and do the custom
docker integration with stage maker
everything has been done for you
for more ease to use
so oh it works
in a nutshell so you build
your script
at the beginning inside the notebook and
you leverage you can leverage the
notebook or the search maker studio or
your own ide it doesn't matter and and
so when you have your script you will
pass it to the the sagemaker
training
container the dlc
and that one will provide a way to train
your model on gpu or cpu as you
requested and from there you can
fine-tune and manage your experiments
when you have your model that has been
built you can deploying using a
sagemaker hosting platform
and if you use that you will have a
automatic scale
from your model endpoints but you can
also download it from
the model download it from s3 and self
manage
the deployment
and so now
it's the moment that you get your hand
dirty
and so you can go to that url dashboard
dot event engine that's run and we
provide the hashcode in that page and i
will work through with you through the
step to access your adobe list
environment uh to to try to
to follow us on that journey for
training and deploying an audio so i
will do it with you let me just grab
the url
up
and the ash code
so i will sum both of them
in the chats so you can follow me
sorry about that
okay thanks dude
and after i you can go through
the email one-time password
so you put here
your email
send the passcode
i will receive it in a couple of seconds
that's
okay receive it
and you land
to to the dashboard here you have a link
to access the lws console you click on
it and you click open the adwords
console
from here you can just accept
everything and
go to stage maker
there is the sage maker console and
today we will use the notebooks
on the left menu
and go to notebook instance
you will see that we have four notebook
already started with
the the workshop pre-installed on on
those and you have the red yellow blue
and green
so you can pick
one of them
and click the open jupiter
from there you already have the
repository that philip shared at the
beginning of the presentation and so you
can click the workshop one get started
with amazon stage maker
here you have
the free notebook we will do the lab one
and just take care that it was not like
running here or that you don't have a
running notebook on that tab yes if it's
the case it's just because someone else
took that instances and so you can go
back and choose another one here
so i will just open that one
and as you can see if i refresh it there
so that is running so if you have a
running instance please just take
another one in the sagemaker one and so
now you are in the notebook and so i
will end up to nate to go through that
notebook
awesome thank you matthew
i'm going to share my screen
beautiful is this coming through
okay great
uh so
yeah so today now what we're going to do
is we're going to train a hugging face
uh transformer for multi-class
classification multi-class text
classification
um what we're going to do is is train a
model that can understand emotion so
given input text so for example i like
you i love you we're going to predict
over six different classes of emotion
in this case you can see that it
predicted love
these are the other available classes
and the data set we're going to use is
the emotion data set
which is available on on hugging faces
hub
so the first thing you're going to need
to do is install any of the required
libraries if you don't have them
already installed
and so that's torch
tensorflow
whatever whichever one you want to
choose today we'll be using pi torch
and then you know sagemaker transformers
and the datasets library
so first we're going to import uh the
hugging face
integration into sagemaker
and then the first thing you always need
to do on sagemaker is authenticate so
we're going to set up a sagemaker
session
and inside this notebook what you can do
is you can call
dot get execution role and that will
automatically pull in your
authentication so you don't have to
worry about trying to point to a
specific role or anything like that so
we're going to run this cell
and we're going to see that you know
this is our our
arn roll this is
the
s3 bucket that we're going to use
and this is the region that we're in
now the first thing that we're going to
do uh is is basically
pull down a data set process it locally
and then we're going to push it up to
that to that s3 bucket so that we can
use that for our training
so
like i said we're going to be using the
emotion data set which is a data set
that consists of sixteen thousand
training examples uh two thousand
validation examples and two thousand
testing examples
um today we're just gonna be using the
training and testing sets this is a very
simple example just to get your hands
dirty so
first things first we're going to define
our tokenizer name
if you're familiar with hugging face you
know that
we have these objects that you then call
dot from pre-trained on and this is a
reference to a model id that's on our
hub so you can actually find any of
these models on our hub just by
searching for this um
now we're going to be using the
distilbert base uncased model so
it's not going to use
a
case
it's not going to be case sensitive
and this distilbert model is actually a
little bit smaller so it trains a little
bit faster i found that it's it's
something that you see a lot in um
in enterprise in production because it
is a faster variant of uh of bert
now again we're going to define the data
set name which is in motion
and then here we're going to lay out the
s3 prefix so this is going to be the
location on our s3 bucket that we saw
earlier
um that our data that we're about to
process here locally in this in this
notebook instance
is going to be saved to when we push it
up so again we're going to process it
locally on in this notebook instance
this this um on this compute and then
we're going to push it up to s3 and then
from s3 we're going to um we're going to
pull down that data from s3 on our gpu
instance later when we go to train
uh so that uh we can use that for
training
now uh the benefit to doing this where
we're processing it locally and then
pushing it up is that uh when you go to
train you're not gonna have to wait for
your data to process on that instance on
that expensive gpu instance so we're
going to process it once on this cpu
instance that i've got here and then
we won't have to waste
time and subsequently money uh in our on
our gpu instance uh to process the data
so uh here we're going to initialize our
tokenizer so
we're going to use hogging faces auto
tokenizer which is basically asking for
a a model id from our hub and it'll
automatically pick the right tokenizer
to
instantiate now
if you're not familiar the tokenizer is
something that's used to take
raw text so something like this a string
and turn it into the input ids that your
model is looking for
um
beautiful so we're going to instantiate
that and we're going to define a
function to tokenize our our uh our data
and that's basically going to take a
batch of data from our data set in this
case the field name is text
and we're going to
pad it and we're going to
truncate any sequences that are longer
than
the
the tokenizer's max length
parameter
now um
this function here is going to actually
load the data set so we'll load it and
we're going to specify that we only want
to load the train and test splits
um
then we're going to
take that function that we wrote and
we're going to map it across the data
set so we're going to map it both across
the train data set and the test data set
and if you choose this batched argument
it's actually significantly faster so
that's what we do here
next we're going to just rename some
columns
the reason why you do this actually is
because uh the data set the raw data set
that is on hogging face comes with this
field called label
but when you pass
batches of data into your model to make
predictions later the hog and phase
model it's expecting a field called
labels
so if we actually change the
field here we can just unpack the
dictionary into the model when we go to
make predictions as opposed to
manually picking out the keys and
passing it to the model
one by one so that's kind of like a
little tip
now
here comes the part where we actually
upload that data so
we're going to
we're going to take the data set that we
just
processed these train and test data sets
that we just processed
and we're going to use the
file system the s3 file system helper
from the data sets library to save that
up to that file system so we're going to
take the train data set and we're going
to save it to
that
that default bucket that we had at that
prefix that we defined earlier
and we're going to split it up by train
and test so this is going to save
just the processed file up to s3
or files rather because we have two
beautiful and now we are ready to
fine tune and start our sagemaker
training job
so what we're going to basically do is
we're going to take that
distilbert base on case model which is a
model that has a general understanding
of language and we're going to fine tune
it for our specific task
so
what we can do
is
well i guess i should go over some of
this here the
the idea is that you're going to define
a training script and if you notice in
our notebook there is a training script
that we'll take a look at here in a
second um
and you're going to point to that so
you're going to you're going to have an
estimator here and you're going to point
to that training script you're going to
tell it where it lives so you're going
to tell it that it lives in the scripts
directory which you'll notice it does
and we're going to define our instance
type we're going to find the
transformers version the pi torch
version we want to use and then we can
define any hyper parameters that we
might want to use as well
these high parameters get passed in
if you're familiar with sagemaker they
get passed in as
flags to your script so you need to
define an argument parser
so i'll go over the script in just a
second
it'll give us a chance to
start the
start the job so that we we can while
we're waiting for the to spin up and
train
we can talk about the script a little
bit more so here i'm going to define
those hyper parameters i'm going to
import the hog and face
integration here
the estimator and we're going to define
our estimator here
and then we're going to
we're going to start training so we just
uh
i ran this cell and we just spun up the
job
and it's going to start training
so let's go back and take a look at and
break down you know what's going on here
um
so like i said these hyper parameters
that you can define they get passed in
as arguments or flags to your to your
script
and we wrote this script up here which
you can see lives in the scripts
directory and it's called train.pi
which is why we specified that here it's
in the scripts directory called
trained.pi
and
the top of our script we're going to
define an argument parser so using arc
parse i'm going to define an argument
parser
these are the hyper parameters that we
that we would like to have um in this
case it's the number of epics for
training the
training batch size the eval batch size
so how many um how many examples to feed
your model during training and also
during evaluation
the number of warm-up steps
the model id
the model id here is going to be our
distilbert base on case
the learning rate you'd like to use and
whether you'd like to use um
uh 16-bit precision for for training
now um in addition to that we're going
to define other flags and these flags
are actually just going to be overridden
by
the your environment variables
when you
run
a sagemaker
job it's going to pass in these
environment variables and specifically
there's going to be the output
directory data directory so that's
exactly where you want to save any
output data your model directory which
is where you're going to want to save
your your model um uh your
the number of gpus that are on your
machine uh how many it's configured to
use
um
and the training and testing directories
so this is where your your training and
testing uh data came in and the reason
why we're going to actually define these
as flags here is because when you're
training locally if you want to run the
script outside of sagemaker for
development purposes maybe on your cpu
just with like a dummy model
just to make sure it works uh this way
you can actually still do that so you
can you can just pass these flags in
when you run it locally and then when
you go run it on sagemaker um it's gonna
just work seamlessly and you don't have
to change your code at all
uh beautiful um we're going to
then after you you know define these
arguments you can parse the args so it's
going to pat parsees from the um
uh standard in um we're going to define
a logger which will help us log things
to
sagemaker so we can keep an eye on
what's what's going on
uh after that we're going to load our
data from uh the disk so you know we
pushed it up to s3 earlier and then when
we start our job we we pointed we said
you know these are the this is the s3
bucket that we want to use for training
and testing and we
pulled that down
when we
sagemaker's going to pull that down and
we're just going to reference that using
this training directory and this test
directory
so we'll load those in and now we have
our training and testing data sets
um
after that we're going to define a
metric and a compute metrics function um
this metric comes from the hog and face
data sets
package so in this case we're going to
use accuracy and
because we're going to use the hogging
face trainer
or sorry the transformers trainer
we we are going to define this compute
metrics function which is going to take
in a prediction object
which is going to include the the raw
predictions as well as the labels so
these are going to be like a probability
distribution um that we're then going to
get a choice from so uh in this case you
know we have six classes so we're going
to choose you know which one did the
model predict is the is the one that the
model thinks is the right prediction and
then we're going to use that metric that
we defined to compute the actual
accuracy across that batch um and this
is you know
this function is how you you could
define any other metric that you want to
that you would you'd want to define so
this is where you could do something
like
you know precision recall things like
that as well
now
this part right here is actually a
little bit of a hot tip
using the data sets library we can
reference the features within the data
set
um so in this case i'm going to
reference that labels feature that uh we
talked about earlier in the trained data
set
and we're going to get all the names of
the the classes so so in this case we're
going to get the if we saw earlier we're
going to get these six names
as a list
and the reason we're going to do that
is because
we'd like to
we'd like to define the labels in our
model so that when we save our model
configuration later um it's going to
have access it's going to know what the
actual labels are to the model as
opposed to just knowing there's six
classes you know like we're not just
gonna predict label one or label four
we're gonna actually predict we're
actually gonna be able to tell the user
what what label it was and you'll see
that later when we go to the the um
the prediction endpoint uh we'll see the
um
we'll see that we're actually gonna get
the label names
um so yeah in this case what you
actually the way that the model is
actually going to expect this is as a
dictionary so we're going to set up two
dictionaries one for uh doing the string
label to the id and then one going id to
the label and both of those actually
have to be strings so that's why you see
us
casting these
indexes to strings
after that finally we're good to
instantiate our model so we're going to
instantiate our model using that model
id in this case distilbert based on case
we're going to define we're going to
specify the number of labels which is 6
in this r case and we're going to give
it those label to id and id2 label
mappings
we're going to instantiate our tokenizer
again because again this is running in a
separate place so even though we
instantiated it up here in this notebook
it's uh you know this script doesn't
know about that right because it's
running independently
and then we're going to use hogging
faces training arguments uh object to
define all the extra arguments that we
um
are going to go into our trainer in this
case this is all sorts of things like um
which learning right scheduler you'd
like to use the warm-up steps for that
um for your learning rate um you know
weight decay uh all sorts of things like
that
after that we instantiate a hug and face
transformers trainer passing it the
training arguments the model that we
defined um or rather the model that we
instantiated the untrained model
our compute metrics function our trained
data set and our evaluation data set
which will end up being turned into
pi torch data loaders
that we'll iterate over during training
and the tokenizer that we use to prop
that we want to use to process the text
finally
we're going to
train
and then evaluate
and uh we're going to print out some
stuff uh at the end so you can see it
and
at the very end we're going to
just save the model to that sagemaker
model directory which is how we're going
to be able to get that model later so um
like i said earlier when we save this
model it's actually going to save our
labels as well that we that we were able
to specify here so we'll actually get
the labels um in the end for
making predictions
now let's check on where our
our training is it looks like it's just
starting training
at the same time just so that i don't
forget
i'm just going to run these last few
cells um
they're not going to run until that one
finishes but i just want to make sure
that while we're chatting here um
uh
you know that can be running in the
background
now uh
this is this visual helps us understand
a little bit more about what's happening
um you know we're interfacing with with
aws through the sagemaker sdk
specifically the hog and face
integration here
and what's going to happen is we're
going to pull in a pre-trained model
from hogging faces hub
at hf.co
and we're also going to pull in the data
set that we that we pushed up to our s3
bucket earlier both the training and
testing data sets
the instance that we're going to that we
chose to train on
is going to
be configured using the hugging face
training container so you don't have to
mess with docker or anything like that
we're going to do training
on that data set um using the hugging
faces uh use using hogging faces trainer
and it's going to save our fine-tuned
model
up to another bucket so we have that now
at an s3 bucket so we have things like
the model the save model the model
configuration
you can get things like the logs you can
pull those down later
then from there
once training is completed we're going
to take that model that we pushed up to
that
pushed up to this bucket right here
we're going to pull that down into a
another instance but this time for for
an inference instance
and
reload it
and then we're gonna be able to use it
anywhere so we can make predictions um
uh right on this instance and you can do
that on the gpu you can do it on cpu um
you can do this for you know large
models small models anything you want um
so
beautiful and we can see here that we're
training you can see some things being
spit out
we just finished our first epic here
and we'll continue to get some
information
um
beautiful
so while we're waiting for that is there
any questions um
that i can answer
yeah maybe emilio asked um can you
please explain um save the model 2 as
free users the environment variable to
make sure checkpointing works maybe i
can pick that up again emilio so what
nate has shown like in the last um step
of the training script basically with
the trainer that's safe and providing
the environment variable will then hang
first transformers the trainer will save
the model to the directory which will be
uploaded to s3 after your training is
done so after all epoch evaluation
everything is run through sagemaker will
pick everything up in the directory
upload it to the s3 bucket and we have
created earlier within the session
and then you can access it directly from
s3 but if you are like interested in
like i'm using spot instances and check
pointing to like continue training or
like train on a model stop and then
continue training on the same model
there's another lap in the workshop the
lab3
which is called um spot instances and it
includes the same script nate went
through
but it in includes also like the
configurations you would need to make in
the hiking phase estimator to use check
pointing and spot instances and for
those who don't know what spot instances
are it's like a special i would say uh
instance situation on aws so aws has a
lot of ec2 instances and when they are
like not used by customer they can get
um
or can be available into like in the
spot instance pool and these can be like
reduced in terms of pricing up to 90
percent so you could for example um
start your training with a spot instance
if it's like not really depending then
you have luck and get a spot instance
and will save um
costs during training but these spot
instances can be automatically like a
stop so if a customer wants to use the
instance type you are using for spot
training and he wants to use it as an on
demand instance he aws basically will
automatically stop your training job and
give the instance to the customer and
with checkpointing enabled um
sagemaker will still upload basically
your current model and the checkpoints
to s3 so you could continue training
right beautiful thank you um also there
is another question
how do you troubleshoot diagnose issues
before or during the training process
for example shape issues sure that's a
great that's a great question so my
suggestion is always always always um
that you're going to be running these
things locally or in a sagemaker
notebook so we can actually
uh
we can actually take this code and and
run it straight from the sagemaker
notebook on cpu um
or you know you can run on your laptop
or you can run it on on sagemaker
whatever you feel is best for your
workflow but you know eighty percent of
your time in development is going to be
spent um you know debugging and working
on making sure your script works um
before you go to launch a you know big
instance on sagemaker so my suggestion
is that um
work on these things either locally or
up on a
sagemaker notebook instance play with
the model make sure that you get your
scripts working correctly and then once
you're ready that's when you can spin up
a sagemaker training job uh to to scale
up your script
so uh if you if you just try to develop
and and execute training jobs every time
you want to uh run your code you're
probably gonna have a bad time
developing because uh you know uh you're
not gonna be able to get instant
feedback but if you
uh if you if you
make sure your script works perfectly
before um it'll work just the same on on
on sagemaker so that's what's great
um uh that's that tends to be kind of
the workflow that you see um whenever
you're using aws you know you you want
to
make sure your stuff works perfectly and
then when you want to scale that's when
you use the training jobs because it's
going to run your code the exact same as
as it does locally so if you're working
if you're having issues with shapes of
things or if you're building something
and you want to add a layer to something
and you're in development uh definitely
use something interactive like a
sagemaker notebook um yeah
any other questions uh yeah like a few
more like from uh rechief i hope i
pronounced it correct does the trainer
function have callbacks similar to keras
save the best model slash plug into
tensorboard or weights and buyers and
early stopping parameters sure yeah yeah
of course um so uh yes the the hugging
face trainer does have of callbacks in
fact the callback that is used for the
default logger which is um tensorboard
uh uh is is a callback uh so you know
you can
define your own callbacks and then use
them for whatever you want so if you
want to add your own logger for
something um you know um
domain specific or or you know specific
to your company you can do that um if
you ask specifically about bond b so let
me show you actually
i believe it's
let me show you on the training script
so
if you wanted to define
that you wanted to use one b weights and
biases you could just add a parameter
here a keyword argument here called
report2 and you could specify that you
would like to report to want b
and you can find that in the docs for uh
training arguments you can find that um
on the hugging face transformers docs if
you search training arguments you'll see
uh the the report to report underscore
two uh keyword argument then that lets
you either specify that you wanna uh
report to
one logger or multiple so you can
actually
report to both tensorboard and weights
and biases which is something that i
tend to do uh where you know maybe when
you're running it you want to be able to
view um
or or other rather uh when you share
your model later on hog and faces hub
you can actually share the tensorboard
log so i'd like to share those there but
when i'm personally developing i like to
use uh ways and biases
but yeah
we have all sorts of different callbacks
that have been written by the community
you can find those online and you can
define your own for
whatever you want
let me pick up a question from mike uh
when you install libraries in a notebook
does the those libraries get added to
the training and inference container no
so basically what nate has done in the
first cell is um he's installing it into
the jupiter environment where um he has
done the processing and part if you want
to include like additional um
dependencies like weights and biases or
tensorboard or maybe something special
on your site to the training and
inference dlc then you can provide a
requirement txt
at your source directory level so in the
estimator we have defined the source
tier and the entry point and if you
place a requirement txt in the source
gear in our case it would be the scripts
folder and at for example the weights
and bias sdk or tensorboard or
i don't know pandas then you have access
during the training for it
and then maybe don't forget
yeah
i i do uh this uh this um
estimator finished deploying so i'm
gonna you mind if i talk about this real
quick
um
so yeah uh we are we finished training
right and we pushed up the the uh the
train model to a
or the fine-tuned model rather to a uh
another s3 bucket
and then we this is how simple it is to
deploy we took that estimator that we
just trained and we're just going to
call dot deploy
and then we're going to we're going to
specify the instance that we'd like to
um the desired number of instances and
then the instance type that we'd like to
deploy to uh so we see that uh we've
successfully um
deployed it and then uh we can just pass
it the
um
pass it this payload here which is going
to be inputs and then i can specify the
text that i'd like to get the
prediction for in this case i say i get
so nervous before a demo
and we can see that uh the label the
predicted label is fear
i love using
beautiful joy i feel joyous
um
so i love using hugging face and stage
mega we got a predicted output of joy
it's a little lower than i would have
hoped it would be um but again this the
script that we wrote here is for demo
purposes it's uh it's a very minimal
example we can play around with the hype
parameters make this model better we can
train it for longer um i think we only
trained it for you know very yeah we
traded for one epic so you know um
you're not gonna get the best results if
you train for one epic but uh for the
sake of example um you know we can see
uh all you have to do is just change
some of these parameters and you're
gonna get significantly better results
um for this this demo we didn't want to
uh train for too long so we didn't keep
you waiting um but um yeah beautiful
that's uh that's the outputs and then
once we're finished we can actually
delete that endpoint uh by by calling a
predictor.delete endpoint um and i'm
just gonna leave this up for a minute so
that we can make any more predictions if
we want to um
how about this one um
uh
now i'm just going to delete it how
about
we'll just delete i won't get i don't
get too fancy here i'll just show you
that you can delete that and now uh
we've deleted the the instance that was
that was being used for predictions and
um and it's no longer costing us money
so you can see that um and just you know
look at this four lines of code where we
spun up a inference endpoint we made
predictions and then we deleted our
endpoint to save uh save money so you
know if you only need your inference
endpoint for a certain amount of time
you're going to want to delete it
as as soon as you're finished using it
so that you're saving you're saving
money
and it's in it is really that easy so
beautiful
okay
um yeah i'm free to answer as many
questions as you'd like now uh phil
yeah i think something we can already
tease because i see a lot of questions a
few questions coming in asking about
more uh inference specific use cases
um
shayanna asked if we can like save all
predictions to a tabular data or also
and
jason asked a bit more about
inference in general so and the next
workshop series we are going to do will
be completely focused about
going production so we have now seen how
you can fine-tune your models and easily
deploy them with the dot deploy method
but i mean going production is not just
like deploying inside a jupiter notebook
there's like more to it if you want to
scale up your your end point with auto
scaling groups that's also stage makers
providing or if you want to monitor your
endpoints making sure they work that's
basically the focus about the second
session where we will have examples on
how you can already deploy fine-tuned
models from the hugging face hub as
finbird for example to sagemaker to run
real-time predicting it is exactly what
nate has done or also batch transforms
and batch transform jobs are basically
what shayana has asked for is you
provide a json line file with 100 or
1000 of like input data and then run
prediction against it and then you get
like the whole file and out of it hit
back with the predictions and search
maker will also again start
an instance for running those
predictions and then we'll stop again at
the end
and we will share more details about um
the next workshop series on social media
but all of you who has attended today
will also get an automatic invite to the
next session
beautiful then maybe a few more
questions to
[Music]
training um lea leontro asked what hyper
parameter do you recommend to fine tune
should we train only prediction head or
retrain the base model digital world as
well
right um so you can play around with all
these things
i believe
training the whole model is actually
what we usually do here
but if you want to see some examples of
some best practices you can check out
the the the transformers on
the transformers repo on github and we
have an examples folder there and some
of the best practices for training
scripts are right there and in fact i
believe um when philip runs his next
example he's actually running straight
from that examples directory so that
tends to be a really good place to to
find these best practices if you you
know what which parameters to use for
what types of tasks you know um
uh what your learning rate schedule
should be how much uh you know uh what
kind of learning rate scheduler to use
should you even use one you know what to
set uh your learning rate as as by
default we try to keep a lot of these
default uh settings and um uh choices uh
uh we try to pick the best default
settings um in this training arguments
object here so if you were to define
almost nothing here except for the
output directory we're gonna try to
choose the the um
the what we think is probably going to
be a good starting point um
but yeah i guess
the answer is i guess depends which is a
really
which i hate giving that answer but
i think a really great place to get some
information on that is the is the github
repo uh the transformers get a repo
and also maybe something to note so on
huggingface.com we have like the models
hub which contains i think close to 20
000 community driven models and all of
them have like those model cards and
model cars usually contain information
about how the model was trained and
evaluated so with scores and a lot of
models also contain like in the training
section which hyperparameter i used for
this model so for example if you also
want to train a model on the emotion
data set and want to get like some
feedback or experience what other has
done you can go to hackingface.com
models and then search there for a model
and then you can find maybe a different
type of parameter settings people has
used before for this kind of task but i
think it's always good to start like a
small and with like the default settings
and then you can play a bit with the
learning rate in the beginning or like
easily increase the epoch size like from
one to three and then to five to see how
your model is like learning
and then if you really want to go deep
you can tools like
optuna ray um to like automatically
optimize your models for a specific type
of parameter um
area
there is a question on discord uh money
i don't know if i'm spelling it right
says a follow-up question on identifying
the right instance depending on the
memory requirements of the model during
inference or general
recommendations he says
filipino checker
yeah so um for inference you can firstly
select between cpu and gpu instance type
for cpu
what we are going to do behind the
scenes is starting like one worker per
cpu core so if you have like a cpu
instance with four cpu cars you will
have four different workers which all
serve the model which is so you have
like four models in parallel and then
for gpu um since we only have one gpu
and we like doing um not like any
special virtualization behind the scene
you will have one worker so i guess the
best way to start is really focus on on
cpu oriented okay which cpu do i want to
use do i want to use like the new ice
lakes from intel or a cascade lake from
intel and then see how big my model is
for example if i have like a default um
distal bird model which is around 250 to
300 megabytes i'm not sure exactly what
the number is and you have four cpus
then you know if you have four
multiplied by 250 and then like add a
few additional
megabytes in memory to yeah basically
load
the input so
i would say like
if you have like um 1.5 the memory um
available for the model size should be a
good fit and then depending on the cpu
you use you get different speeds for
inference and the better and the newer
cpu of course the better
your influence time will be
there is one more question
what are common issues when running
prediction jobs in notebooks
for example
if the deployment faces errors during a
prediction task will we see those errors
output stack trace in your running
notebook
yeah so maybe um nate if you can scroll
to the um where you started the training
a bit
um
there you can um
see
yeah
yeah a bit um yeah exactly there you can
see everything what's happening inside a
container so that's basically produced
inside of the container in the beginning
you have like some configuration and
logs about the environment and then when
you scroll down a bit you will see a few
output logs and then at the end you also
will see um the transformer specific
like evaluation you are doing or you see
like the progress files of your training
and if your training runs into an issue
you can directly see it there and then
sagemaker will also of course take care
that the instance type is stopped you
can look into the arrow make your fixes
and then right run estimator dot fill
again
okay uh phil i think um
i think it might have been about
inference specifically do we have can we
get these logs um for this part here
um yeah to get like the inference locks
you would need to go to the um sagemaker
console again where material started in
the beginning and then next to notebooks
there's like also an inference um tab
and then you can see an endpoint and if
you click on endpoint you should see
your deployed model and then there's a
few locks button
which will like point you to the locks
and then you can see basically what's
happening inside
your endpoint
beautiful
we have another question
how would you keep all these process
report reproducible can you for example
deploy the notebook script from a github
action
right uh so i think phil will be
actually showing exactly how to do that
later uh so great question um there's
you can actually use you can specify a
git repo
by url and you can actually just use
that um
you could run straight off of that so
yes you can you can reproduce the
experience um
based off the github repo
my suggestion would be to keep a keep a
careful eye on your requirements when
defining a requirements.txt file um you
know pin uh or limit the versions that
you're that you're gonna be using so
that um
so that it continues to be reproducible
because if you you know leave your your
uh requirements open things might get
updated and things might break later
down the line because that's the beauty
of open source things are always
changing so uh just make sure that
you're you're pinning your requirements
um and you should be all good um phil
you wanna uh say anything else on that
yeah so in addition to like make things
reproducible sagemaker has something
called sagemaker pipeline which is a
service i introduced re invent last year
which helps you building end-to-end
pipeline um like automatically and also
search maker something called stagemaker
experiments which is
pretty similar to
um ways and biases where you can like
lock all of your hyperparameters so you
can add such maker experiments to your
training and then you it will create
like different runs of your fine tuning
script and it will also save like the
metrics output so you have like all of
your hyper parameter and the output what
it has achieved
and and this will be all tracked inside
the sagemaker platform so you can always
take a look at the different runs you
will run or if you don't want to use
sagemaker you of course can use weights
and biases or tensorflow to lock your
hyperparameters and then like use github
actions or and any other ci tool to like
automatically start those training
scripts so for example if you don't want
to start a training from a notebook
instance you basically could convert
what nate has done to a normal python
script and then it runs from top to
bottom and this python script can be
executed anywhere you want
awesome uh anything else i don't know
where we are on time here too
we have a few more minutes left to
answer a few questions
i'm going to take this opportunity to
just call out uh please join the discord
uh it's going to be a great place for um
you know to see things from the
community um so not just for today's
event but also um in the future it's a
great place for us to all connect
and it's a really good solid place for
updates and things like that on hugging
face um
speaking of discord we can uh pick up
this question on discord from nua mani
um who asked a question relating to
something we answered already earlier um
is there a special technique how we can
determine how much of like memory we
would need to run our training so if
like data set from for examples and a
model with the size of um epsilon can we
like is there any like um rule how i can
select like the best batch size of gpu
to use
well i think uh
what i'm more worried about usually is
not uh cpu memory but again i don't
wanna i don't know what your you know
what kind of data sets you're working
with so this might be something that's
very um
um
it's a big bigger problem for you uh but
a lot of these instances have enough
memory if you're using some of these gpu
instances i don't even have to think
about cpu memory but if you are using a
cpu version um
uh you can you could probably you know
uh
run smaller scripts and check out check
out what kind of usage you're using um
and and kind of go from there and then
kind of you know cross reference that
with the different instance types or you
know what you could do if you're if
you're worried about memory uh usage on
uh cpu instances you know just spin up a
few training runs and see if they work
they would see if they work that's what
i would probably do you know like your
script's gonna work so
you know you could run this these like
four lines of code like five times
across a few different instances and
just choose the one the the smallest
instance that works or the cheapest
instances that works for you um that's
probably a good solution too
and maybe also something to point out so
we have a in high effects with the
training arguments uh we have something
called max steps so you can for example
define only like 100 mark steps and then
the training will stop so
uh define max steps or fiber parameters
set it to 100 and then you can like fast
try different like batch sizes on
different instance types and then if you
like found the right fit you can like go
with it and if you like go on to the
stage maker like dashboard and into the
training category and training jobs
there you will find all of the training
jobs you run and the stage maker is also
reporting the gpu memory utilization so
you can um
if you after you started your training
job with on the p3 instance with like
patch size of 16 you can go to the
search maker and dashboard into training
into your training job and scroll down
to like the instance
metrics utilization and there you can
see how much of your gpu memory is
basically used and if you see your kids
like 50 percent or something then you
know you can probably like double the
size of your batch size if it's close to
9200 and you know okay i'm have like a
good batch size for my
training data set
beautiful um any other questions uh merv
there is there are two
is there a way to chain multiple models
in a pipeline in sage maker
uh first paraphrase the text content run
named entity recognition and then
extract embedding and then ingest to
face
uh
so in general yeah uh i i think phil
probably answered this a little better
than me uh but my first thought on that
is if you want to chain multiple models
together you could probably um uh
you could probably deploy a couple of
them and then just pass them to each
other but i don't know if that's the
best solution i'll let they'll uh phil
answer that
yeah i think what nate said is
definitely something you could do or for
example have a lender function and then
multiple endpoints behind the scenes but
um with you maybe you can say something
about uh the sagemaker um
pipeline or i think processor pipeline
where you could do like some kind of in
sampling predictions
yeah exactly so you you can do that with
the section maker processing pipeline
where you you shine
multiple
inference endpoints together
okay maybe to answer one last question
from stefan and how does this compare
with infinity so maybe for those um who
are following hugging face
last month we released a new service
called hugging face infinity and which
is a containerized solution for low
latency inference for transformer models
and how does it compare so i would say
with stage maker you can like easily
train and deploy your models and
infinity and like uses those models to
optimize them like to one millisecond
latency to run predictions and then you
can like run infinity on sagemaker as
well so i guess like an optimal process
would be usage maker to find your new
model easily deploy to run a few tests
or like build a proof of concept using
sagemaker endpoints and then if you like
have really like latency requirements
down to like a few milliseconds you can
then go to infinity optimize uh with
multiverse for your infinity container
and then if you really want to um run it
on such maker again that's okay infinity
is compatible with sagemaker so you can
get all the benefits of the stagemaker
platform with auto scaling
and like having these this easy endpoint
to deploy and if you want to deploy
somewhere else that's also an option to
do
beautiful
great should i pass this off here
yes
okay great i'm gonna stop sharing
so thank you for for joining the session
will be um or the recording will be
shared afterwards on discord and
definitely keep an eye on discord or on
our social media platforms we will share
the next workshop um soon
and happy to see you there
bye